pour cette rentrée 2010 8 au cinéma les
yeux d'elsa on va essayer de récupérer
de rattraper des films qu'on a raté cet
été donc vous pourrez redécouvrir ou
voir under the silver lake film
américain avec andrew garfield black
klinsmann qui a vu le grand prix à
cannes
évidemment mais surtout mon petit
chouchou le monde est à toi un film de
romain gavras qui est sorti le 15 août
au coeur de l'été et qui a pas eu le
succès qu'il mérite à mon avis alors
c'est un film qui est soutenu par
vincent cassel et isabelle adjani
vincent cassel joue le rôle de riton qui
sortent du tout juste de prison d'une
petite frappe
enfin voilà un bandit de deux petits
chemins de la pègre française et puis
adjani qui joue le rôle d'une sorte de
flamboyantes parieuse escroquent qui
escroquent même son fils qui est joué
par karim le clos qui est une seule une
vraie révélation dans ce film
ce jeune homme en fait dans le film joue
le rôle de quelqu'un qui a le rêve de
développer la franchise mister freeze au
maroc
évidemment ça va l'amener dans des
péripéties complètement folle qui font
de ce film un vrai film policier un
thriller une comédie d' aventure
formidable le monde est à toi donc que
vous pourrez retrouver à partir de la
semaine prochaine et pour deux semaines
au cinéma les yeux d'elsa